[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Please join me
in welcoming Xenia Rubinos
to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - XENIA RUBINOS, "MEXICAN
CHEF"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Does anybody know
what bachata is?
Uh huh.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you
want me to tell you?
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah why not.
What's bachata?
AUDIENCE: It's like a
Latin type of a dance.
It's not salsa, but
more of a sensual dance.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah.
Bachata-- he said bachata
is like a Latin dance.
What did you say,
is more sensual?
AUDIENCE: I think
it's more sensual.
XENIA RUBINOS: OK.
It could be.
It's a dance style.
It's from the
Dominican Republic.
But it's also music.
Check it out.
Just put in "bachata" in
your Google search engine,
and find out what it is.
Ask Google.
Yeah, bachata-- so
I'm saying bachata.
In the back people are
like, what are you saying.
That's what that song is saying.
[MUSIC - XENIA RUBINOS, "LAUGH
CLOWN"]
[APPLAUSE]
That one was called
"Laugh Clown."
And this last one, it's
called "Just Like I."
You guys OK out there?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah?
Taking the temperature?
You guys all right?
[MUSIC - XENIA RUBINOS, "JUST
LIKE I"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
VIVIEN LEWIT: That was amazing.
XENIA RUBINOS: Thank you.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Oh my
gosh that was so great.
Round of applause for Xenia?
[APPLAUSE]
XENIA RUBINOS: Thank you.
VIVIEN LEWIT: So I had--
I had this very distinct
way, I was going to order--
I was going to ask
you a questions,
but I have to start with
something different.
XENIA RUBINOS: OK.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Because
you said something
while you were up here, and I
think it was really profound.
And I don't know that
every performer when
they get on stage gets that
overtaken by their music.
And I wanted to
ask you about that,
because you sing that second--
XENIA RUBINOS: "Laugh Clown"?
VIVIEN LEWIT: "Laugh Clown."
And you said, I lose myself in
that sometimes, or something
to that effect.
So when you are up on stage
like this and you're performing,
and that feeling overtakes you,
what's going through your mind?
How do you feel about your
music in those moments?
XENIA RUBINOS: I'm not
really thinking on a--
kind of like a rational
level, and that's
really the problem mostly.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Problem
or not a problem.
XENIA RUBINOS: It
can be a problem.
Yeah, I'm in like a dream state,
when I'm at my best I think,
to be connected to performance.
And I'm really grateful anytime
that I get to share my music
and perform it, and
for that experience of,
you know, receiving energy from
people that I'm performing for
and also giving that energy out.
So when I'm in that
cycle, that circle,
I spin out sometimes when
I'm kind of in a dream state.
Which can be a problem if
like I let my emotions kind of
take over, if I let my
adrenaline take over.
I can do things that--
I could hurt myself or I
could like jump on people,
or do all kinds of things
that I'm known to do,
but then I don't remember after.
You know, I'm not like present
in that rational sense,
in that moment, and then
sometimes I'll see a video
and I'll be like, I
was dancing like that?
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even know
I could do that.
I'll be like, why
do my knees hurt.
I'll look at the
video, and I'll see
that I was doing like these dead
drops-- like doing like pow!
Like doing all
these crazy things.
And I'm like, I don't
even remember doing that.
Good thing I didn't
split my pants.
But it happens.
VIVIEN LEWIT: And you usually
play with a band, right?
XENIA RUBINOS: Yes.
Currently, my setup
is a four piece band.
So I am free to sing mostly,
and I play a little organs
in this current setup.
But it's myself, my drummer
Marco Buccelli, and then a bass
player and guitar or keyboard.
VIVIEN LEWIT: So if things
get really out of control
they can--
XENIA RUBINOS: They
usually are just--
VIVIEN LEWIT: They
probably let you go.
XENIA RUBINOS: They're
on the back line.
They're holding it down.
Yeah, they're usually just
like, what is she doing today.
VIVIEN LEWIT: That's amazing.
Yeah, I think we all need
to see you with the band.
You know, when you're
performing in the area.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah, come out.
Yeah.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Great.
So this is a really
exciting time for you.
You're on your second album.
XENIA RUBINOS: Mhm.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Your first
record was released
in 2013, "Magic Tricks," yeah?
XENIA RUBINOS: Yes.
VIVIEN LEWIT: And then
this album, which I think
is so beautiful-- they're
both so beautiful,
and they're sonically
so different.
What is your process
when you write music?
What's your inspiration?
XENIA RUBINOS: Thank you.
Well, I usually
start by improvising.
So I usually start
a writing session,
first with something
that I know,
whether it's a song that
I like or a song of mine,
or something that I know
to kind of just warm up.
And then I usually
start improvising either
with just my voice,
or on an instrument--
a instrument like a
keyboard or on the bass.
In this case, I wrote
a lot of the album
on bass, which I don't
know how to play.
Really, I just I bought--
I went and I bought a bass,
because I was demoing the song,
and I needed a bass
player to play the lines.
And nobody would show up
that day, so I was like,
well I guess I'm just
going to buy one.
I'll return it--
I guess I shouldn't say that,
but I'll return it later
when I'm done.
But I was having so much fun,
I decided to keep the bass.
And so I ended up writing a
lot of this record on that,
but usually it's
just improvising.
And I try to just let
myself go for a little bit,
and then I start
to hear some bit,
whether it's a rhythm that
I'm playing or I'm singing,
or it's a melody
that's happening.
And I isolate a small bit of
that, and then I repeat it.
So I repeat it to find out more
about it, through repetition.
And usually when I find
out something about it,
then something else
happens that changes,
and that's usually how
an idea starts for me.
VIVIEN LEWIT: So it
builds organically.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah, through--
Yeah, through improvisation
and listening.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Do
you think the fact--
because the first record was
very synth and organ sounding,
and the "Black Terry Cat" is--
there's something smoother
or more jazzy, more melodic
about it.
Do you think any of that
had to do with the bass,
with you just
pulling out that bass
and beginning to write
the record with it?
XENIA RUBINOS: Definitely.
Writing a lot of songs
on bass, you know,
influenced-- the sound of the
album is very bass centric.
A lot of the melodies came from
playing on that instrument.
VIVIEN LEWIT: It's
really rhythmic.
XENIA RUBINOS: Mhm.
The first record was kind of a
piano trio, power trio record.
So it was very minimal with
bass drums and keyboards mostly,
there's not much else
in the sound palette.
And in this record, I
expand that a little bit.
And I did more vocal
stacks, like in my--
in the vocal arrangements,
I have these kind
of fat vocal stacks
of layering that I
haven't done as much before.
I used to loop my
voice and use my voice
as kind of like horns
and different textures.
Which I'm still doing on
this record, but I expanded
the sound palette
a little bit more,
with more synth, some guitar.
But I think ultimately
what changed on this album
for me was also the music I
was listening to at the time.
So I was really into--
I was discovering a
lot of hip hop music
that I didn't know about,
some groups like Slum Village.
VIVIEN LEWIT: No.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yes.
VIVIEN LEWIT: I
represented Slum Village.
XENIA RUBINOS: Really?
VIVIEN LEWIT: Yes.
XENIA RUBINOS: [GASP]
XENIA RUBINOS: Were
they good clients?
VIVIEN LEWIT: I was
a music attorney
before I joined YouTube in 2011.
And in 1997, I think--
'96?
I represented this artist
named Slum Village,
and I didn't know that
anybody knew Slum Village.
XENIA RUBINOS: Girl.
VIVIEN LEWIT: [LAUGHING]
XENIA RUBINOS: I was--
Yeah, that was some of
J Dilla's masterful work
at the beginning.
VIVIEN LEWIT: The producer
who was Slum Village--
XENIA RUBINOS: J Dilla
produced those tracks--
VIVIEN LEWIT: But there was
another artist, his name was--
Bryce was his last name.
XENIA RUBINOS: Oh gosh.
VIVIEN LEWIT: I won't remember.
XENIA RUBINOS: You caught me.
You caught me on that one.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Really
hilarious reference--
XENIA RUBINOS: Oh,
they're incredible.
Yeah.
Black Moon and J Dilla.
I mean, just discovering
sampling kind
of for the first time.
I mean, I knew what sampling
was, but I was just kind of--
I haven't really been
digging into that music.
I kind of was coming
out of a period
where I was discovering
punk for the first time,
and I had been listening
to jazz for a while,
but I had kind of
been suppressing
some of those interests in my
music-- or not suppressing now,
I was just on another tip.
And this time around I was kind
of digging into this music,
going back listening
to Busta Rhymes, who I
listened to as a child as well.
Listening to Kendrick Lamar's
album, "To Pimp a Butterfly,"
was also really
influential for me,
at the time that I was
finishing this album.
That album came out, and I
was thinking about lyricists,
rappers, and people who
use their voice, you know,
to tell stories.
And listening to
Kendrick's album,
and how he sounds like 10
different people on one album.
And thinking about different
ways to use your voice.
So all of those things
influenced me on this album.
I wanted it to be really
beat driven, really soulful
and funky, and
also kind of focus
on the vocal performances.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Right.
Right, well what you do with
your vocals is incredible.
XENIA RUBINOS: Thanks.
VIVIEN LEWIT: So
"Pitchfork" got it right--
I pulled a quote that pitchfork
referred to your music as,
"adept at punk confrontation
as R&B run-ons."
Which is very interesting
to have punk and R&B
in the same sentence.
And then from--
there's also outside
of the sound, the music,
there's really deep messages
in the work on this album.
And the last one too, but I
wanted to focus on this one,
because when you
performed "Mexican Chef."
What are you trying to convey?
XENIA RUBINOS: Well, that song,
"Mexican Chef," just started
out as kind of an observation.
I was walking around
running errands
in my neighborhood in Brooklyn,
and there were kitchens
that we're setting
up for the night.
And they had the back
door open, and you
could see the kitchen
staff, like you know,
cleaning up, setting
things up, prepping.
And they were blasting bachata,
and rancheras, and salsa.
Today in the Google
cafeteria actually
they were listening to
salsa like on blast.
I was like, what's up?
Who's playing all
this old school salsa?
And they were
like, Yeah, we are!
What's up?
So that was cool.
But so all of the kitchen staff
was listening to this music,
and then in the front
of the restaurant
the wait staff
was mostly white--
and the kitchen staff
was mostly Latino,
and in the front
of the restaurant
was completely different sound
palette, completely different
kind of music playing.
And I just thought
it was so funny.
So I started kind of
improvising on these words.
I thought was writing
a short story,
or like a funny rhyme to myself.
I didn't think anything of it.
And when I got home, I
just wrote it all down,
and I thought it was just
kind of making myself laugh.
It was a joke, you
know, but then it
ended up becoming that
song "Mexican Chef."
So people are responding to--
have responded to it a lot,
in terms of saying that it's
very political and very social.
Which I guess it is very social,
but I didn't intend for that.
I didn't set out to
write a song like that.
I was kind of just having
fun, and observing things.
But my mom used to
say when I was a kid,
I always remember her
saying this one thing,
that the hands of brown women
welcome you into the world
and clean you.
And you're an infant, and
welcome you in the hospital.
And they're the same ones that
kind of take you out of this--
not take you out, but take care
of you when you're on your way
out.
They are the same ones
who take care of you
when you're on your way out,
in nursing homes and stuff.
My mom worked in a nursing home.
She's a registered nurse.
One of her first big
jobs in this country.
So yeah, she talks about
the labor of brown people.
So that's kind of
what I'm referring
to in the song is a kind of
somewhat invisible workforce
that, you know, makes
our cities function.
Especially in a
city like New York,
but all of these big
metropolitan cities
where we have all of
these incredible services.
You can have your laundry--
you can have your
clean underwear
delivered to your
doorstep if you want to.
It's absurd, but you
know that's the luxuries
that we live in these cities.
And a lot of the
times, the people
who actually make those services
function are people of color.
So it's kind of a shout
out to that workforce.
VIVIEN LEWIT: That's great.
I've had the experience.
I've been in the nursing
home with my parents
and had that experience
that you're referring to.
And I've had the experience
of birthing, my own children,
and having exactly
the same experience
that you're referring to.
And both were beautiful.
So when you think about
your processing your music
and the meaning,
you know, there's--
I think that, as an artist,
you have your own perception
of your music, and then you have
all these external accolades
and critiques of your music.
Are they the same for you?
Do you feel about
your music the way
that you read people
writing about it,
and the way you hear or see
people responding to you?
XENIA RUBINOS: Well, it's like
when you look in the mirror.
The eyes that you
see yourself with
are totally different
than the eyes
that others see you with,
that a lover sees you,
or a stranger sees
you, you know.
So no, it's not
the same, you know.
You know, sometimes
there are synergies.
Sometimes when I'm
performing I might be--
that day I might have
been working on something,
and channeling something where
I might have been listening
to like an Erykah Badu
song or something before I
come on stage.
And then after the show
someone will be like,
oh you remind me of Erykah Badu.
And I was like,
whoa, that's weird.
And I'm like
channeling, you know.
Like just because in that
day I think that I was maybe
channeling that
or projecting that
through our transfer of energy,
like somebody received that.
So I think that kind of
stuff happens sometimes,
where someone will
perceive something
that is a new thought for
me that I'm working on,
and in that way we'll agree.
But a lot of times I'm
surprised, you know.
And it's fun.
It's fun to see how people,
you know, perceive your work.
Sometimes more than
others, you know.
But cause--
VIVIEN LEWIT: How do you want
the music to make people feel?
XENIA RUBINOS: Well, I would
like people to feel joy,
and to feel enraptured
by my music; to feel
inspired to listen to
music or to make something
when listening to my music.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Do you do
any other form of art?
Do you write?
Do you paint?
Is there any other kind of--
XENIA RUBINOS: I
wish I could paint.
I can't even draw--
I can't even draw like
a square or a circle.
It's really sad.
But I do enjoy writing.
I've just been in a fight with
words for like a decade now.
So I'm working.
Something I'm working
on-- something
I was working on
this album, I wanted
to work on my lyric
writing a little bit,
because I felt like that my
first album I relied a lot
on kind of figurative language.
And a lot of my lyrics were
super open to interpretation,
which they always are,
but I was wondering
what it would be like to
approach lyric writing
in a more literal sense.
And I guess one of
my big fears is--
two big fears is talking
about things I don't know
and just adding to
the noise of people
just talking about things
they don't know about,
and the second was about
being corny or cheesy.
Like being so literal
that it's corny.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Right.
XENIA RUBINOS: So now,
I just went for it,
and I was, you
know, was literal.
But writing is something
I'm really curious
about, and interested in.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Right, there are
some artists and songwriters
that actually put
down the lyrics first,
and they create music to
it, right, or vice versa.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah.
Yeah, in my case, I've always
done it the other way around.
The sounds, the melodies,
and rhythms come first,
and the lyrics have
always been last.
But on this record, I was I
was like, no girl, you go in,
and you write the words down.
What does that mean?
So I was trying to
be more specific.
And you know, it was tough.
The only way I convinced
myself a couple of times
just being like,
don't worry, you're
going to throw it
away afterwards.
Like no one will ever see this.
So I just had to--
it can be petrifying
just to be that specific.
And now, you know, we're just
always throwing out words all
the time to each other, you
know on Twitter or whatever.
We're just always like,
blah blah blah blah blah.
Everything is--
everyone is so entitled
to say whatever they want all
the time, and write it down,
you know, and maybe not
always think about it before.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Do you
use social media,
in like promoting your
shows, or things like that?
Your music.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah I do.
It's complicated.
Yeah, we have a
complicated relationship.
We're working on it.
It's a work in progress.
VIVIEN LEWIT: I don't
think you're only
artist that has a complicated
relationship with social media.
You know, one is--
and you probably feel this
also, is there's so many
different places to go
to reach your fans today.
And you know, I hear
sometimes from artists,
well I'm on YouTube, and I'm on
Twitter, and I have Facebook,
and I have Instagram, and I have
Snapchat, and I have WhatsApp.
You know, it's like the
litany of different outlets,
and where should I go first.
And where should I reach my fan.
And I think it's kind of
difficult when, you know.
And I think some
artists will just
select one place to really
focus on, and build a fan base.
I don't know.
How do you address that?
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah, I
just have fun, you know.
I think ultimately
people can tell
when you're not about
something, just in general.
Like if you're playing a song
that you don't believe in,
or that you don't like what
you're doing, people can tell.
So I think, you know,
audiences are smart,
and people are smart, smarter
than we give them credit for.
So I think like trying to
be genuine in all of those
things-- so you know, I might--
I tried Snapchat, but it
just makes me feel old.
I don't understand
what's going on.
I can't ever find--
like trying to respond,
trying to do the thing,
but I can't figure it out.
But yeah, I just try to have
fun, and figure out my way
and not force things, you know.
VIVIEN LEWIT: What's your
favorite song to play?
XENIA RUBINOS: Oomph.
"See Them," which is a
jam I didn't play today.
That's kind of like a b-side
jam from "Black Terry Cat."
And it's kind of a choose
your own adventure song,
except I chose it for you.
[LAUGHING]
But it kind of is-- kind of has
some similarities to a through
composed piece, which is
a piece that would have--
if your sections are lettered,
it would just be ABCDEFG,
and it would never repeat.
It would just go from one
direction to the other.
So I kind of set out
in this structure
of writing this thing
that would never repeat,
but then that didn't happen.
I ended up repeating
a couple of sections,
but it still has it's kind
of longer development in all
these different sections.
And I have so much
fun playing that,
like too much fun
playing that song live.
I need the help of
my band to play it,
because there's so
many layers going on.
Otherwise, I would just
be pressing a button
and singing to tracks.
But I love playing
that song live,
and seeing how people are
connecting with it physically,
it's cool too.
VIVIEN LEWIT: When are
you playing in the area?
XENIA RUBINOS: I just
played in the area.
You just missed me.
Yeah, I just had my homecoming
show a couple-- like a week ago
or something.
I just finished my first
ever headline national tour.
VIVIEN LEWIT: That's fantastic.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah, thanks.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Where did
you-- where do you go?
XENIA RUBINOS: All over the US.
I went to Canada.
I drove from coast to coast.
Went to the South.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Amazing.
XENIA RUBINOS:
Went to the middle.
I went to the West.
Went to the East.
Went to the North--
VIVIEN LEWIT: I watched
your tiny desk performance.
You must have done that
in the middle there--
XENIA RUBINOS: I did
that, I think this summer.
They tape them in advance.
Yeah, that was fun.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Those
must be so much fun.
XENIA RUBINOS: I
was really nervous.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Have you guys
seen NPR tiny desk performances?
I love them.
XENIA RUBINOS: I
was very nervous.
But we got we got through it.
VIVIEN LEWIT: It's
probably a little nerve
wracking in that space.
XENIA RUBINOS: It is,
and also, you know,
it's a lot of heavy
music cats in there,
you know, that have played
there and that work there.
So it was like, whoa, you
know, but we got through it.
Yeah.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Speaking
of heavy music cats--
I wouldn't have asked you this
question, but you said that.
Who would be the one
person, the one musician,
that you haven't met yet
that would be most inspiring,
and, you know, cause
you to write more and--
XENIA RUBINOS: Should've
told me that one before.
VIVIEN LEWIT: I know.
You could think about it
while I'm going to ask--
to really ask if anyone in the
room has any questions or--
anything more
you'd like to hear,
that you'd like
to share with us?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So when I was first listening
through "Black Terry
Cat" I was thinking, OK this
is a little more political.
But the thing that kind of
turned me around on that
was the song "Laugh Clown,"
which you just performed.
So in the first line, you
talk about how, you know,
you're letting your
eyebrows grow back and--
XENIA RUBINOS: My mustache.
AUDIENCE: Your
mustache as well, yes.
And that kind of spun
me around, because--
I found that
political, but then I
questioned why I found it
political, because in effect
like, as a default
state, your body
is a statement to
the rest of society.
And-- and that's really--
I think that also applies to
some of your other statements,
like in "Mexican Chef,"
that, you know, this
isn't necessarily you
going out to be political,
but I see that in this society
your body is political.
So could you comment
to that at all?
XENIA RUBINOS: Oomph.
Yeah.
Well, it is interesting.
Thanks for the great
question, by the way.
I think that by virtue
of just being who I am,
looking how I look and where I
come from, and being a woman--
a lot of just observing,
and just saying what I see
or what I've lived, is
political, you know.
It's just as simple as that.
But it may not be
of someone else.
You know, maybe if you were
to say something that you saw,
or something that
you lived, it may not
be perceived as
political, but just
by virtue of me telling you
my experience it's political.
Maybe because there
are less people who
look like me in certain
contexts and situations that
are expressing, you know, their
lived experiences and things
that they see.
So, you know, that's one thing.
And I think that this album,
this work, is really personal.
The song "Laugh Clown,"
at the beginning,
I'm really talking more
about like personal hygiene
and the passage of time,
and how I'm-- you know,
I was also working through
depression and grief, and--
and kind of having that
beginning for me personally
is about I'm just--
I'm over it.
Like I'm not even caring, like
when like I'm looking at myself
I'm like, whoa.
I didn't pluck my
eyebrows for a month.
Like what's going on?
What's the deal?
But it's more about just
being in that kind of state.
But I do but I am also in this
album talking about brown girls
and people of color--
brown boys too.
And, you know, talking
about body issues.
I have a song called
"I Won't Say,"
where I quote a piece
from one of my heroes.
Maybe that's who I would like to
meet, Abbey Lincoln, vocalist.
She was a contemporary
of Billie Holiday,
but she's a little
bit less well-known.
And Abbey's work and voice
is so rich and so beautiful,
and has a lot to say
a lot of commentary
about things that
she's lived and seen.
And she wrote an essay
that was published in-- it
was called "Negro
Digest" at the time.
I think it might be "Ebony" now.
And it's called "Who Will
Revere the Black Woman."
And it was talking
about how in our society
the black woman is kind of
disposable and thrown away
and not championed, and her nose
is too wide, and her, you know,
her feet are too flat, and
her face was too black,
and all this kind of thing.
So in this-- and I cite some of
that in my song, "I Won't Say."
And I'm dealing with some
of these body image issues
that are universal, you know,
regardless of your ethnicity.
You know, of feeling
like you don't fit in.
You know, just like kind
of universal things.
But so ultimately, this work
is very personal for me,
even more so than political,
but it's the other--
it's the others who
do the othering.
It's the others who say
that I'm being political,
but I'm just sharing
my personal experience.
I don't know if that
answered your question,
but a couple of
thoughts on that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
XENIA RUBINOS: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
First I just wanted to say
this is kind of weird for me,
because earlier this week I
found out you were coming,
and I was just like, oh shit!
And I got here really
early, because I
was like this place
is going to be packed.
I can't believe
she's coming here.
And now I'm just
like, apparently,
I have to tell everyone to
listen to you, because they
haven't already.
But I was wondering two things.
First, have you always
lived in Brooklyn?
Or I guess just wondering
about where you grew up,
and how that like
influenced you.
XENIA RUBINOS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Also wondering your--
just more of your musical
influences, I think.
I don't know if you listen
to it, but I kind of--
I'm reminded of like
early Regina Spektor
sometimes with your like vocal--
VIVIEN LEWIT: I see that.
AUDIENCE: It's
like, I don't know--
it's nice.
XENIA RUBINOS: Cool, thank you.
Yeah, tell everybody
listen to me.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Just not
Googlers, I guess.
XENIA RUBINOS: Aha.
It's all good.
It's all G.
VIVIEN LEWIT: We're
going to spread the word.
XENIA RUBINOS: Happy.
Happy to be here.
I am not from
Brooklyn originally.
I've lived here in New
York City for 10 years.
So I guess that's a cut off
that makes you a real New
Yorker, right, like 10?
I heard.
I don't know, whatever.
But--
VIVIEN LEWIT: I give it two.
XENIA RUBINOS: Two?
VIVIEN LEWIT: I don't know.
Like New York's a
really hard place.
Like if you can make it
two years in New York,
you're safe to call
yourself a New Yorker.
XENIA RUBINOS: OK.
VIVIEN LEWIT: I've been
living here for 20.
XENIA RUBINOS: Well, so you
are definitely the real deal.
VIVIEN LEWIT: 22.
XENIA RUBINOS: So you've
got me beat times two--
two and a bit.
Well I'm--
VIVIEN LEWIT: Oh my god, 24.
XENIA RUBINOS: Oh my!
Time flies when
you're living life.
Yeah, so I was born in
Hartford, Connecticut.
So it's just two hours
north of here, smack
dab in the middle of
the state Connecticut.
And I've lived my
whole life here
in the Northeast of the states,
and I guess the majority
of my life in Hartford.
And that is a very
oppressed city financially
and culturally, which
is ironic because it's
like one of the richest
states in the country,
but there is a lot of poverty.
There's a lot of
cultural oppression.
There's not much
going on arts wise,
although you know folks are
always constantly working
to change that.
But a very racially
segregated city.
Very large Hispanic
community that lives there.
My mom is from Puerto Rico,
and my father was from Cuba.
And they met in
Hartford of all places.
I'm like, really?
I could have grown up on a
beautiful Caribbean island.
But so that's where they
met, and in the 70s,
there was an effort
to recruit laborers
for the industries in Hartford.
There was a Colt--
huge Colt weapons
manufacturing companies--
huge industries in
Hartford, and they
needed people to come and work,
probably on the cheap side,
in these factories.
So they actually went to
Puerto Rico to recruit workers,
and offered them housing.
And I think--
I have to do more research, and
I'm very curious on this topic,
and I hope to be
able to do it soon.
But I think that was how the
ghettos were built in Hartford.
And I always wondered like how
did all these Puerto Ricans end
up here in this cold place,
this cold unfriendly kind
of climate.
My mom was always
like, oh you know
it's like somebody's
cousin said it was there
was work there, somebody's aunt.
It's always like
somebody's family member
told them to go for work.
But I've recently
read that, about kind
of like this recruitment
effort in the '70s, which makes
sense of why so many Latinos.
But that's where I grew up.
And I couldn't wait
to leave, you know.
And I spent a lot of my teenage
years, I guess as many of us
do, like wanting to get
away from where I was.
My family was great and very
supportive, and very loving.
I came from a very
loving, supportive home.
Not musicians, no
one in my family
is a musician, but music lovers.
They love to dance
they play music
at all the family functions,
as many Caribbean folks do.
So I grew up dancing to salsa.
I grew up listening
to classical music.
My father who was the Cuban--
my Cuban side, he grew up
listening to the radio.
Classical music, he discovered
on the radio in Havana,
and he had a lifelong
love of classical music.
And for him, modern music was
like Stravinsky or something.
So he wasn't sure like
what I'm trying to do.
VIVIEN LEWIT: How old were you
when you started playing music?
XENIA RUBINOS: Well he--
took me to like a toy store,
and there was a piano in there,
I guess when I was like four.
And I supposedly sat
down on the piano,
and really couldn't
stop playing.
I don't know if it was me who
did that or if it was him,
because he had always
wanted to be a pianist.
But in that time it
wasn't acceptable for men
in that community to be
artists, because it would imply
that something about
their sexuality,
or it just wasn't an
acceptable career choice.
VIVIEN LEWIT: In Cuba?
XENIA RUBINOS: In his community.
I don't know if that's
true for all of--
VIVIEN LEWIT: When he was
in Cuba, but not after he--
XENIA RUBINOS: No, no.
Yeah, as a child, when
he was growing up.
Maybe it was something
in his household.
His dad was not a
classical music fan.
He would say that's
music for dead people.
Like, don't play that
when I'm here or whatever.
So anyway, my dad says
that I couldn't, you know,
stop playing the piano.
So he got me the piano,
and I couldn't wait.
He was like, oh she's going
to be a pianist, or like she's
going to be an opera singer.
But then I was like, I really
like Mariah Carey actually.
I just want to--
I just want to like--
[SINGING] I just want to
do my Carey songs all day,
and he didn't.
He was like,
[SPANISH ACCENT] if you
want to be like
Mariah Carey you need
to learn how to read music.
I was like, really?
You sure?
Can I just not--
So he encouraged me to
choose another instrument,
aside from voice, to learn
also how to read music.
And so I started lessons, and
he like met people at my school.
He was always into
something, trying
to encourage me to be musical.
And met somebody
at the school who
was able to fund a scholarship
for me to study privately,
and that's how I learned
how to read music.
Yeah.
And some of my musical
influences, I mean,
I grew up listening
to classical music.
Ravel is one of my favorites.
His beautiful piano sonatas.
And hip hop I talked
about earlier, J Dilla.
It was important for
me to discover Bjork
when I was in my 20s, which I
when I first heard her album
"Post" I was like, what is--
I don't understand what this is.
I hadn't ever listened
to electronic music.
I didn't know what that meant.
I didn't know what
she was doing.
It took me like a good year
to really kind of come back
and realize the
depth of, you know,
her compositions
and her sound world.
And that was really
inspiring to me too.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
XENIA RUBINOS: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So music is probably
one of the main reasons
I ended up moving to New York.
And I especially like
listening to bootlegs
from places like Arlene's
Grocery and places like that.
Or Jeff Buckley
playing at Sin-e.
But a lot of those
places are gone,
or they still exist but they're
in a different location.
And I'm kind of curious what
your favorite places are
to play around the city, or
to see new music that you
are discovering?
XENIA RUBINOS: Oh yeah,
that's a great question.
There's a newish
venue in Brooklyn,
called Come On Everybody,
that has a really great
curatorial program.
A lot of diverse
groups playing there.
It's not one-- it's not
specific to one style or one
social scene.
It feels like there's a lot
of different kinds of music
coming through there.
And it's a new space and
a very welcoming space--
feels like a safe space
for people to gather.
So I really like going there.
It's one of my favorite venues
to just kind of hang out
at and check out music.
Trans-Pecos, in Ridgewood,
is also a really great venue.
That's run by Todd P,
kind of a famous promoter
who kind of came up during
punk shows and DIY shows.
He runs Trans-Pecos, and
also the Market Hotel
that just recently
reopened also in Brooklyn.
So there are a lot of great
venues to check out music--
check out music.
I guess one of my
favorite spaces
that I've ever played in New
York, that I love the sound of,
is Bowery Ballroom.
I mean, that room sounds
incredible, and the house
engineer--
VIVIEN LEWIT: Agree.
XENIA RUBINOS: is a legend.
Like you know, such a
pleasure to work there,
and I love that, the
sound of that room a lot.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
XENIA RUBINOS: Sure.
VIVIEN LEWIT: But that is
actually a great question,
because I was going to Sin-e
and Arlene's, and Brownie's.
You know, it was like there was
a scene in the East Village,
and then it moves
further down to Ludlow.
And then Arlene's
opened, and Sin-e closed.
And everything just kind
of kept moving south.
And then it moved into Brooklyn.
In the 10 years that
you've been here,
have you seen a radical shift?
I mean, I spent some time in
LA, I spent time in Nashville,
and there's been a
little bit of an exodus,
it feels, for musicians
and artists from this area.
XENIA RUBINOS: Oh yeah.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Do you sense that?
XENIA RUBINOS: Oh absolutely.
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, when I moved
here 10 years ago,
you know, the
Williamsburg of today
had nothing to do with the
Williamsburg of even 10
years ago, and I don't even know
about before that, who knows.
But yeah, I used to hang
out a lot in Williamsburg.
I had some my first shows
there, at this place
that was called
Galapagos, that used
to be on North 6th
Street right next
to what is now Music
Hall of Williamsburg.
Then they moved to
Dumbo, and then there's
a big article of them
like moving to Detroit
and buying a fabulous
building in Detroit
for like $5 or something.
So there's all of that--
yeah, that kind of stuff
going down for sure
in the last 10 years.
And lots of great venues--
Glass Lands on North, you know--
oh geez-- on Kent, Kent
Avenue, that whole scene
there with Glass Lands.
There's another place,
called Monkey Town,
that was my hang out.
That place was wild.
It was like this cube
room, really small.
You could probably fill like
30 people in there, maybe.
Or maybe it was
100, I don't know.
But it was all
these video walls,
you know, that you were
surrounded by and then
these couches, and the artists
would play in the middle.
And they would have like--
kind of this like
video music sets,
like veejay sets, and
mostly experimental stuff,
like late night vibes.
But it was such a great space.
And so many great venues
that have moved on
and don't exist anymore, but
there are new places to play.
But of course, a lot
of recording studios
also have shut down
and moved away.
You know, it's an
expensive city.
It ain't cheap.
We get all those services we
were talking about earlier,
you know, it's not
cheap to live here.
So that's not conducive
to folks who are maybe
trying something new, and
starting new adventures
or new businesses.
It can be a little
challenging, certainly when
real estate is pricey when
your rent is too damn high.
I don't know if you can
say it on here, but--
You know, that that's
the vibe for sure.
But there are still--
I love New York City.
I love living here.
I've met incredible people.
And I meet new people working
on really exciting ideas a lot,
and that's what keeps me here.
VIVIEN LEWIT: That's great.
Well, thank you so
much for being with us.
XENIA RUBINOS: Thank you.
VIVIEN LEWIT: Fantastic.
XENIA RUBINOS:
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]